onze jours après les inondations
dévastatrices dans l'est du kentucky joe
biden s'est rendu sur place pour
constater l'ampleur des dégâts au moins
37 personnes y ont perdu la vie pas le
moment donc de célébrer la victoire des
démocrates au sénat dimanche les
désastres naturels se multiplient aux
etats unis un rappel quotidien de
l'urgence climatique
on n'abandonne jamais dit il on ne
s'incline pas si on va de l'avant en nez
ce vol et le sénat et aller de l'avant
la veille
espace
en votant pour le projet doit de plus de
700 milliards de dollars sur la
réduction de l'inflation avec une
importante enveloppe budgétaire de 369
milliards de dollars pour le climat
c'est le plus gros investissement en
environnement jamais effectuées aux
états unis l'objectif réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 40%
d'ici 2030 le gouvernement encourage
l'achat de voitures électriques en
offrant un crédit d'impôt qui ira
jusqu'à 7500 $ et pour les panneaux
solaires 30% de l' installation sera
prise en charge
[Musique]
ça a été une longue douloureuse on dit
il mais nous y sommes arrivés oui car
sera pris 18 longs mois un véritable
marathon pour rallier tous les sénateurs
démocrates
en santé plus de 60 milliards de dollars
sont prévus on parle de médicaments
moins chers car le médical pour à
renégocier les prix attractifs également
les personnes âgées vulnérables ne
paieront pas plus que 2000 $ par année
pour leurs médicaments
le gouvernement byden compte aussi
récolter des sous désormais les
compagnies qui font des profits depuis
d'un milliard de dollars devront payer
15% en impôt minimal ce qui pourrait
générer plus de 250 milliards de dollars
une mesure qui irrite et républicains
embauché 86 mille agents du revenu
supplémentaire lance le sénateur
républicain lindsey graham ne vous
leurrez pas ajoutent ils ils vont aller
chercher les services des chauffeurs
d'hubert pour récolter le plus d'impôts
possible la chambre des représentants va
voter sur ce projet de loi avant que le
président ne signe le texte pour qu'il
devienne loi et démocrates espèrent que
cette victoire va leur donner un nouveau
souffle à 92 jours des élections de
mi-mandat 6 à 0 2 les galeristes
radio-canada washing